[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHET HAASE: Hi, welcome to
the animation talk on Friday
afternoon.
We are opposite a
[? Colin ?] talk,
so I think that means that
everybody in this room
didn't want to hear about
[? Colin. ?] Which is perfect,
because we don't have any
[? Colin ?] on our slides.
So, welcome, to the
not [? Colin ?] talk.
I am Chet Haase.
I'm from the Android
UI Toolkit team.
DORIS LIU: I'm Doris Liu.
I'm also on the Android
UI Toolkit team.
CHET HAASE: And we're going
to tell you a little bit--
actually, a lot--
about animation.
We're going to talk
about small changes that
were made to the existing
animator's stuff.
Small, but very important, and
deceptively tricky to implement
features.
But, more importantly,
Doris is going
to tell you all about a new
physics-based animation system,
starting right about, now.
DORIS LIU: Clicker.
All right, so today,
I'm going to talk
about physics-based animation.
You might be
asking, why would we
need a physics-based
animation library?
A few years ago, before I
joined Android Firmware team,
I was an app developer,
just like some of you.
I wanted to create a swipe
animation for the Google camera
app, and I had the camera menu
moving in a beautiful waveform,
along with a gesture.
I'd also track the velocity of
the gesture up until the moment
of finger release.
Then, I thought to myself--
all right, now the only
thing that's missing in this
is getting the camera
menu to continue
the momentum of the gesture
once the finger is released.
So I looked into the
Android animation framework
for an API that
can take velocity
as one of the
starting conditions,
and close the gap for me.
I looked, and looked, and
there was no such API.
If you've had a similar
experience building animations
in your app, you're in luck.
Because, today,
we're going to talk
about the new physics-based
animation library
that we have just released.
You might be asking, how is
this new physics-based animation
library any different than
the existing animation API?
Well, if you're familiar with
the existing animation API,
you know in order to
create an animation,
you need to provide a start
value, an end value, duration,
and an interpolator.
Velocity-- that's
just an afterthought.
Once such an
animation is created,
velocity has to be derived
from other properties
of the animation.
Given that, it's
extremely difficult
to create an animation
that can continue
the momentum of the gesture
once that's leading up
to the animation.
But with physics-based
animation,
it can handle the
different gestures
with the different
velocities much easier.
Different gestures from small
swipe to a really fast fling.
Also because the movements of
the animation in the new system
are governed by
real-world physics,
they look more
natural and lifelike.
And the new system can also
respond to updated user input,
and dynamically change the
target value of the animation
during the animation.
Now let's take a
look at how different
animation systems
handle this target value
change during the animation.
Here, we're using
an object animator.
I think some of you might
be familiar with this.
And, the target
value is indicated
by the position of the
green ring on the bottom.
As you can see, the ring had
moved before the animation
is finished.
And usually, the way we
handle this is we would stop--
we would cancel the
ongoing animation,
and then reconfigure the
animation using the new end
value, and then
starting it again.
But, the problem with
that is, as you can see,
it leads to a really sudden and
abrupt change in the movement.
And if we look at the velocity
chart for this animation,
the blue and red curves in here
represent the velocity x and y.
At the moment of
target value change,
the velocities are dropped
immediately back down to 0.
And that's because we have
canceled the ongoing animation.
And then the velocities
will start changing again
once the new animation starts.
But this discontinuity
in velocity
can create a really jarring
experience for the user.
In contrast, here's
physics-based animation.
When the target value is changed
in physics-based animation,
we interpret that as a
change in the physics force.
And then the new
force will continue
to act upon the existing
velocity of the object, which
is why we won't see a
velocity discontinuity.
And in this example we can see
the transition to a new target
position is really smooth.
And, similarly, let's look
at the velocity chart--
we're no longer seeing any
discontinuity in the velocity,
and that is the key
to a smooth animation.
At this point, you
might be asking,
so what exactly is this
physics-based animation?
The way we define it
is it's an animation
that's driven by force.
And based on the force we can
calculate the acceleration
or deceleration,
which we can then
use to calculate and
update the velocities
and values for the
animation, until finally,
when the force reaches
equilibrium, that's our signal
to stop the animation.
First, let's take a
look at Fling Animation.
Fling Animation starts
with the initial velocity--
and usually that's the
velocity of your gesture--
and then it would
continue that momentum,
and then gradually
comes to a stop.
The force behind Fling
Animation is a friction force,
which is proportional
to the velocity.
What that means
is, velocity will
undergo an exponential decay in
the duration of the animation,
and that will produce a very
graceful end to the animation.
And, by the way,
this Fling Animation
is exactly the API
that I was looking for,
years ago, when I was building
the animation for the camera
app.
Now let's see an example
for the Fling Animation.
Here as you can see, I'm fling
this list from left to right,
and the orange dot is indicating
the position of my finger.
And the list just took off at
the same velocity of my gesture
and then gradually
come to a rest.
Now let's see how
this is achieved.
In order to get notified
when a fling gesture occurs,
we need to create
a gesture listener.
And once the fling
gesture is detected,
we receive this
onFling callback,
with a down event, an up
event, and a velocity,
both x- and y-axis.
Now, we'll be using--
and they'll be in the unit
pixels per second, which
is also the unit that we'll
be using for the velocities
in the new animation system.
And now we're ready to
create a Fling Animation.
To the constructor of
the Fling Animation,
we need to provide the
object we want to animate.
In this case, it's that
list of bearded androids.
And the property that
we want to animate,
in this case, that
is the square x,
since we want to fling
this list horizontally.
And now, we're going to
set the start velocity.
Here you can see I
have [? inversed ?]
the velocity of the gesture,
and that's because here we're
animating the scroll property.
The scroll property
is sort of special,
in that a positive change
in the scroll value
would actually move the list
in the opposite direction
as a positive velocity would.
And then, we're also going
to set min value and max
value to define the
range for this animation.
Fling Animation
will end immediately
once it reaches either its
min value or max value.
And I would encourage
you to set a good value
range for your animation,
so that as soon
as the animation
goes off screen,
it should stop right away.
Otherwise, the
animation might go on
for too long without making
any change on screen,
while it would
request for redraws
and consume a lot of battery.
And finally, we're
setting friction
to control the rate
of deceleration.
Now we're ready to start.
So this is all it takes to
create a Fling Animation.
Now let's take a closer
look at the fling friction.
Here, I'm going to create
an animation for the view's
SCROLL_Y property,
with a starting
velocity of 5,000 pixels per
second, and a friction of 1.1.
And then, I'm going to
create another animation
with the exact same
setup, except we're
going to double the friction.
And if we run these two
animations side by side,
we can see how the
friction affects
the look of the animation.
As you can see, here, with
a smaller value of friction,
the animation would go on
for much longer, whereas when
the friction is
higher, naturally,
it decelerates the
movement a lot faster,
causing the animation
to stop a lot sooner.
You can configure the friction
to whatever positive value that
looks good for your animation.
In addition to Fling
Animation, we've
also introduced Spring Animation
in our new animation system.
Now first let's create
a Spring Animation.
Here to the constructor
of the Spring Animation,
we're going to supply the
object we want to animate.
In this case, it's a view.
But, it doesn't
have to be a view.
It can be any object.
And then the property we want
to animate, in this case,
is a TRANSLATION_Y of the view.
And then finally, the resting
position of the Spring.
Now we're ready to start.
So this animation
with the animated--
the view from
whatever translation
that he had at the start of
the animation to-- back to 0.
Now here's what it looks like.
As you can see, as I'm pulling
this little android down,
his moving is TRANSLATION_Y,
while stretching the spring,
as it goes.
And then once I let go, that's
when the spring animation
would start.
And then, the
TRANSLATION_Y would
start from where I
released it back to 0.
You can see, it bounces back
up and oscillates a little bit
before he rests at a
TRANSLATION_Y of 0.
And if you feel
adventurous, you can also
change the bounciness
of the spring
by simply setting
the damping ratio.
Here we're going to
set the damping ratio
to not bouncy at all.
And that's what we
see in the animation.
If you look at this
animation, and you
feel like, this
doesn't really match
your taste for
Spring Animations,
we have an easy fix.
You can simply change the
damping ratio to high bouncy,
and then you will have
a very bouncy animation,
with a lot of oscillation
before it finally settles.
In addition to
damping ratio, you
can also change the stiffness
for the spring, which
will control how quickly
the object returns
to his resting position.
And we'll take a look
at that in a moment.
Now, before we
start the animation,
we can also set some starting
conditions for the animation.
For example, if we set
the start value to 200,
this animation will go from the
TRANSLATION_Y of 200 back to 0.
And also we can set
the start velocity
to match the existing
movement of the object,
creating a continuous motion.
We can also set the min
value and max value,
like we did for Fling
Animation, and define
the range for the animation.
Now we're ready to start.
Let's take a look at the
stiffness, from low to high.
Here we have-- if you
look on the very left,
when the stiffness is
very low, the spring
compresses rather slowly
after it is stretched out
of its resting position.
So when the stiffness gets
higher, towards the right,
it bounces back up much faster.
And these are the
force, spring, stiffness
constants that we have
already defined in our system,
because they each provide
a somewhat unique look.
You can use one of these
already-defined constants,
or you can use any positive
float value for the spring
stiffness in your animation.
Now that we've seen how
we can animate translation
using Spring
Animation, let's see
what we can do when we
combine the rotation
and translation together
in the Spring Animations.
Here we have an example of that.
As you can see, as
this list flies in,
each individual head
sort of shakes around
as if they were hanging
on to a clothesline
they were pulling in.
To achieve this, we need to
apply a rotational spring force
on each individual head, along
with a translation animation
to slide this whole list in.
First, we need to rotate
each individual head.
We need to go through all
the items on the list,
and for each item we will need
to create a Spring Animation
on his rotation property.
And you may have noticed, here,
I'm using a different Spring
Animation constructor,
as we did before.
And this constructor
doesn't require
a third parameter, which is the
resting position of the spring.
When using this constructor,
the spring animation
won't create built-in
spring force.
And it will instead expect
a custom spring force
to be passed in.
And that's what
we're going to do.
We're going to create
a custom spring
force of a resting
position of 0,
and a damping ratio
and stiffness,
that looks good for this
particular animation,
arrived at through
careful experimentation.
And you might ask,
why do we want
to use a custom spring force,
instead of the built-in spring
force?
And the answer is, by creating
a custom spring force,
we can then share this spring
force across all the spring
animations for the children.
Note this is only viable when
all the spring animations here
expect the same spring constants
and the same resting position.
And finally, we can set the
start value of the rotation
animation to minus 25,
so that each head would
rotate from a minus
25 degree angle,
and then oscillate
around 0 degree
and eventually come to a stop.
Now that we've rotated
each individual head,
we still need to slide
this whole list in.
We can do that by creating a
Spring Animation for the list
on his translation x property.
And similar to the
rotation animation,
we are going to configure
the spring constants.
Here, we're going to
use the same spring
constants as we did before.
And finally, we're going
to set the start value,
so that the TRANSLATION_Y
will start from 400
and then slide back into place.
So we've seen Spring
Animations on rotation
and with translation.
What if you want to
animate something
that's not a view property?
Well, good news is, Physics
Animation supports that.
Here's an example of that.
As you can see, when I tap
on the little mustache icon,
all the items just pop in,
blow up beyond its normal size,
and then shrink
back down, making
a very dramatic entrance.
And we could achieve
this by creating not one,
but two spring animations
for each individual child--
one on his SCALE_X
property, the other one
on his SCALE_Y property.
So the each
individual head would
be able to scale along both
x- and y-axis, uniformly.
But, that's a lot of work.
Now let me show you a
different way to do this.
Imagine, what if view
group had this property--
let's call it child scale--
and whenever child
scale changes,
the view group would
propagate down that change
to all its children, in both
the SCALE_X property and SCALE_Y
property.
And in that case, we can
just animate this one child
scale for the viewer
group, and then we're done.
Even though view group doesn't
really have this property,
we can create one for it.
Here, we're going to create
a custom property using
float property compat.
And we're going to have
to override the set value
and get value.
Whenever the child
scale changes,
we will receive this
set value call back.
And in that, like
we mentioned, we're
going to pass down the
change to all the children,
and then change their
SCALE_X and SCALE_Y
property, uniformly.
And, in the get value--
since we're assuming
all the children
to have the same
scale, we can just
return the scale of any child.
In this case, we'll just
return the first child.
Now that we've created
this custom property,
we can put it in an animation.
So, we're going to create an
animation on the child scale
property for the list of beards.
And again, we're going
to set the stiffness.
If you remember, stiffness
changes how quickly the object
return to its resting position.
Here, because we want the scale
change to be more graceful,
we want to use a low stiffness.
And finally, we're going to
set the minimum visible change.
And this is a method that
we haven't seen before.
What it does is it provides
the animation system
a hint as to when it would
be a good time to stop,
so that the animation
doesn't go on
for too long without making
any visible change on screen.
And the reason we haven't
seen this method before,
in all these
previous examples, is
because up until
this example, we
had it animated only the
built-in view properties.
And when we use-- when
we animate built-in view
properties, the animation system
can derive such a value from--
based on which property
is being animated.
If you create a
custom property, you
will need to provide the
smallest change in your custom
property that can make a
visible difference on screen.
In our case, we're
animating childScale,
which is essentially
a scale property,
so we're going to use the
already defined constant--
min visible change scale.
And then, we can set
the start value to 0.5,
so that the scale animation
starts from a half scale
and then blow up.
And then, eventually,
it will settle
at scale of 1, its normal size.
So we've talked about
Fling Animation.
We've also seen
some cool effects
from the Spring Animations.
Let's see what we can create
by combining these two.
Here, we're going to use
the same example as we did--
our same list as we did
for the Fling Animation.
As you can see, I'm flinging
this list back and forth.
But, as the Fling Animation
gets to the end of the list,
there's still some
velocity left.
There's still some
remaining energy.
And that's when the list
starts to stretch out
and snap back,
like a rubber band.
This is a very playful way for--
to dissipate the
remaining energy
when arriving at
the end of the list.
And I think that
you'll agree with me,
this is a much better
experience than harshly stopping
the motion and losing
all the momentum.
In order to achieve this, we
first need a Fling Animation,
and we're going to just use
the same Fling Animation,
as we did before.
Except, this time, I'm going
to call out the setMinValue
and setMaxValue.
These defined the
range of the animation,
like we mentioned before.
But this range ensures
that the Fling Animation
would end immediately
upon reaching
either end of the list.
And that's when we can start the
Spring Animation to then take
over whatever momentum
that it has left.
So in order to start a Spring
Animation right after the Fling
Animation, here we're going
to use an onAnimation update
listener.
Once the Fling
Animation finishes,
we'll receive this all
animation callback with a Fling
animation, whether
or not it's canceled,
and then the scrolling value
and the scrolling velocity.
If the velocity is
high enough, then we're
going to create the
Spring Animation
for the stretching effect.
And we're going to create
the Spring Animation
for this whole list on
his SCALE_X property,
so he can stretch horizontally.
And, as always, we're
changing the spring constants
to make the animation look
good, for this particular case.
And finally, we're going
to set the start velocity.
Here, you might notice, I'm
not using the velocity that I
received from this
callback, because that's
the scrolling velocity,
which is a pixel-based.
And for our scale
animation, we want something
that's in terms of scale.
We can do that conversion by
simply dividing the velocity
by the size of the menu.
Now before we
start, we still need
to configure one last thing,
which is the pivot point.
And that's for the scaling.
As you can see, I'm
really flinging this list
back and forth, and depending
on which way I'm flinging it,
I want the stretching to go
the same way as the scrolling
direction.
So when the velocity
is negative,
the list is scrolling
to the right,
and I want the stretching to
go towards the right, as well.
That requires us to pin
the list on his left side,
and we can do so by
setting the pivot x to 0.
Similarly, when the list
is scrolling to the left,
we want to pin the
list on his right side.
And we can do so by
setting the pivot point
to the right side
of the list, which
is the width of this list.
What we've seen, each
individual animations,
each individual Spring
Animations in the past slides--
I think we can create something
that's more advanced, and more
complex, if we build on top of
that, such as Chained Springs.
Here we have three views
that are chained together
via spring force.
And you can see, I'm
dragging the top view around,
and the white circle
indicates the drag point.
The other two views would
follow as the top view is moving
around as if the three of them
were attached to each other
by a bungee cord.
Now let's take a look at
how we can achieve this.
Let's name these three
views Lead, A, and B
for easier reference.
So our goal is to have
A follow the lead,
as Lead is being dragged
around, and B follow A.
And we're going to achieve this
by using Spring Animations.
Let's first take a look at how
we can have A follow the lead.
So first we're going
to create animations
for a, on its TRANSLATION_X
and TRANSLATION_Y properties.
And [INAUDIBLE]
touch listener where
we're going to process
the touch events
and move the lead view around.
We're going to first--
for each move event, we're
going to compare this event
against the last event
in terms of position.
And then if we
calculate the delta,
and this delta
would be the amount
of movement of the finger.
And then we're going to apply
the delta to the lead view's
position, so that the
lead view would be moving
the same amount as the finger.
Once the lead view's
position is updated,
we want to update
the position of--
or the animation for
A, so it appears like A
is following the lead.
And, here, we're going
to use a method called
animateToFinalPosition.
And we haven't seen
this method before.
It acts one of two ways.
If the animation
has not yet started,
this method would set the final
position for the animation,
and start the animation.
If the animation is
already started--
is already running--
then this method
would just update the final
position for the animation.
And what this means is, every
time we receive a move event,
we're going to
move the lead view.
And then, if A is
at resting position,
we're going to start
animation to move
a towards the lead view.
If the A is already
animating, then we're
going to update
A's final position.
So that, if you remember, in
one of the earlier slides,
the way physics-based animation
handled target value change,
A would, eventually-- after
some course correction--
it would, eventually, head
towards the lead view.
And this is how we achieve
having A follow the lead.
And finally, we're going
to update the last position
for the motion event--
for the delta calculation.
Now let's take a look at how we
can have B follow A. Similarly,
we're going to create
animations for B.
And, in order to get notified
whenever A's position is
changed, we need this
onAnimationUpdate listener,
and we're going to add the
listener to A's animation.
You need onAnimationUpdate
callback.
We're going to receive A's
animation and then A's position
and A's velocity.
We're going to do
the same trick.
Here, we're going to call
animateToFinalPosition.
So if B is not
moving at the moment,
then we would set the
final position for it,
and then start the animation
to move it towards A.
Or if B is already
moving, we're going
to update its final position
so it will eventually
head towards A.
So the physics-based
animation is available, now.
It is [INAUDIBLE] 26 Beta
1, and you can use it
by adding this dependency
to your Gradle file,
and it is backward-compatible
to API 16.
[CLAPPING]
And I'm very excited to see
what you guys can come up
with using this library.
[CLAPPING]
CHET HAASE: Awesome.
So that was the cool, new
stuff, but what if you're still
using the cool, old stuff?
So, that's what I'm here for.
So animator set-- there was
long requested functionality,
in terms of being able to
seek within an animation,
as well as reverse.
We have this in the
Value Animator API,
but not in AnimatorSet,
because it was difficult to do.
So, now we have
these capabilities,
and I'll show a simple
demo and some code that's
not written in [? Colin, ?]
and you can see how to do that.
So there's a famous
quote that I think
everybody probably knows--
seek and you shall find.
It turns out, that this
was taken out of context.
The full quote goes
something like this, seek
and you shall find that there
is no seek API on AnimatorSet.
Right?
Nobody knew that, but I'm
here to tell you that.
Also, it turns out that
there's no way to reverse it.
But, we did some
things about that,
and I'm going to show you how
you can use that functionality.
So here we have a really
simple, rather lame demo.
What I want to do--
given this amazingly
complex UI--
is move those three
buttons around
on the screen when the user
clicks on the various controls
there.
So, in particular, when
you play the animation,
I want the button on top
to move to the right,
the button in the middle
should move down to the right,
and the button on the bottom
should move straight down.
So, the button when
it moves to the right,
you create an object animator--
fairly straightforward.
We're going to
animate TRANSLATION_X
and we're going to move
it all the way over
until it's positioned all
the way over on the right.
The bottom-- the
button in the middle--
we're going to move
it to the lower right.
Similarly, we create
an object animator--
we can use property values
holders so that we can animate
x and y at the same time,
inside the same single object
animator.
So we're doing TRANSLATION_X
and TRANSLATION_Y in parallel.
And finally, the
button on the bottom
is going to move all the way
to the bottom of the screen.
Similarly to the
one at the top, it's
going to animate TRANSLATION_Y
all the way down to the bottom.
So we create these
things, and then we
create the AnimatorSet
that contains these child
animations.
We're going to run
them in sequence.
So it's going to go--
top, middle, bottom.
So we'll play
those sequentially,
and then we start
the animation, which
looks something like this.
I bet you couldn't guess what
was going to happen there.
So you press the Play button--
animation plays.
Fairly straightforward.
That's what you
could do already.
But, what happens
if we actually want
to seek within the animation?
Well, now we call
this new method
called setCurrentPlayTime.
So we've hooked this up to
the seek bar at the top.
So when we get a callback into
the onProgressChange method,
we can see where the seek bar
is in that track that it's in,
and interpret that as a
percentage of movement,
and then apply that to
the AnimatorSet animation.
So, setCurrentPlayTime using
that percentage, multiplied
times the total duration
that the animation has.
So we have this getTotalDuration
method on AnimatorSet--
we get that, multiply it times
a percentage, and away we go.
So we drag it around
on the screen,
buttons move, all
the child animations
are moving
independently, depending
on where we've seeked in the
AnimatorSet animation itself.
All right.
And then, finally--
I bet you couldn't guess
how this is going to work.
What if we want to
reverse the animation,
so the user clicks on
the reverse button,
and everything moves in reverse?
Very straightforward.
It turns out that the
entire quote is now amended,
and it's now--
until now.
So, please use reverse and seek.
[CLAPPING]
And get the capabilities
that you want.
A couple of notes on that.
One is that it will specifically
seek within child animations
that are a value animator.
Because if it's not a value
animator, or an AnimatorSet,
we're not sure how to
reverse or seek that thing.
So if your child animation
is just an animator--
it's this opaque thing that
you've implemented-- we're not
sure what to do about it.
That will get
dropped on the floor.
Or you can implement
that functionality.
But, it's really, specifically,
for the common case
of value animators and object
animators subclass of that.
Another thing to
note is there is
new onAnimationStart and
onAnimationEnd callbacks
in the interface--
default methods
that we implemented that will
then provide you the direction.
So in addition to knowing when
you're starting and ending,
it's useful if you
know what direction
you're running in, given the new
capabilities that AnimatorSet
has.
So you can access
those, as well.
And that is the talk,
and we do have--
sure.
[CLAPPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]